es un secreto que guardo durante casi 40
años
tenía 16 años cuando llegué al
monasterio según esther pérez fue
violada por un monje mientras pasaba sus
vacaciones en una abadía era sólo una
adolescente si tiene un luz y se quede
en una habitación pequeña y desde mi
primer contacto con el monje él cerró la
puerta de sus manos comenzaron a tocarme
para pérez dijo que estaba plenamente
consciente de lo que estaba haciendo el
niño dice dijo que había sido perdonado
que había sido perdonado por lo que no
estaba haciendo nada malo mezclo eso con
la oración y dijo cosas que en
retrospectiva eran pseudo espirituales
estaba equivocado bueno pero me hizo
pensar que era mi culpa porque yo era
especial sentí muy especial ella ha sido
perseguida por el recuerdo del abuso
pero le contó a su madre hasta que
cumplió 40 años
y la reacción de mi madre fue yo lo
sospeche debiste haber sufrido en ese
momento pensé que finalmente podía ser
libre pero al día siguiente ella cambió
de tono le dijo a mis hermanos que todo
había sido una puesta en escena
espiritual tras esto perdí el contacto
con mi madre ella no quería verme y no
la había en diez años hasta que murió
después de años de silencio pérez
testificó ante la comisión independiente
que investigue el abuso sexual en la
iglesia católica no me creyeron y pensé
que era maravilloso es una pena que no
haya sucedido antes pero es genial
finalmente pude vivir sin sentir que
llevaba una maleta llena de piedras
conmigo interés acababa de terminar sus
estudios de psicoanálisis a los 54 años
ahora libre del peso de su secreto